I drove the electric 2016 tesla p90d all
over New York and it was faster more
comfortable and more practical than I
hoped
so here are a couple things that you
should know about the tesla p90d this
new version of the Model S looks like
the past versions
it has the sweet 21 inch wheels
the panoramic glass sunroof the swoop
sides the SiC LED daytime running lights
and the rear spoiler that they do and
like other models it gets the equivalent
of a whopping 89 miles per gallon in the
city and 98 miles per gallon on the
highway put it in ludicrous mode and
you'll feel a major change it is
blindingly fast when everybody says the
ludicrous mode is faster than any other
sedan you can go ahead and believe them
because this thing will blow your mind
when you get in you really push it down
the car will hit 60 miles per hour in
2.8 seconds that's as fast as a
Lamborghini or McLaren but unlike those
cars the speed on this is a
straight-line of acceleration
there's no pause for gears to shift
that's one of the benefits of it being
electric and the company claims that the
car hits 1.1 GS so it feels unlike any
other car to date Tesla has continued to
refine and improve the interior
technology the 17 inch touchscreen
center console works seamlessly to
control music navigation climate and
battery usage
the range is roughly 300 miles the seats
provide ample supported room for long
backs long legs and tall heads the rear
has that famous extra two seat option
but I like the enormous trunk you get
when you stick with the standard five
seat configuration so out of all the
amazing features and cool technology and
software in this car there is one thing
that stood out to me as something that's
a little off and it's a fact that to
shift you shift on the steering column
like the old cars from the 50s and 60s
like you literally pull it down to go
into drive and push it up to go into
reverse which is kind of nuts because
everything else in the car is a
touchscreen or a button Tesla has done a
great job of making sure we get a lot
for our money here everything from the
forward and rear cameras Wi-Fi and
navigation are included in the $70,000
base price but choose things like the
carbon fiber spoiler range upgrade and
high fidelity sound package not to
mention the ten thousand dollar
ludicrous mode and the numbers quickly
add up the price tag of the car I drove
was almost one hundred and forty
thousand dollars it's not cheap but
believe me you'll get your money's worth
and then some
you